This episode of Dnews is brought to you by
Domain.com
Dinosaur evolution seems pretty straight forward.
Creepy lizardish thing, to creepy raptor thing,
to slightly less creepy chicken.
but what if evolution reversed itself?
Hey everyone, Julia here for DNews,
Dollo’s law, named after 19th century Paleontologist
Louis Dollo, states that once a structure
is lost in evolution, it’s lost forever.
But sometimes, on a rare occasion, the past
pops back up.
Researcher Alexander Vargas and others from
the University of Chile who analyzed modern
birds discovered one such case.
They found an ancestral wrist bone may have
made a comeback.
The ancestors of some dinosaurs walked on
all fours and needed strong wrists with 11
bones to support their weight.
One of these bones is called the PIE ZAH FORM
pisiform.
When some dinosaurs started walking on just
two legs, the wrists changed.
They weren’t so good for getting around,
but they were pretty good at tearing apart
prey.
In the change they lost some weight and some
bones.
This wrist had just 3 bones.
The pisiform either disappeared or became
so soft it left no trace in the fossil record.
When dinosaurs took to flight, the wrist changed
again to be more flexible wing.
These early bird-like raptors evolved a different
type of wrist bone, the ulnare.
To figure out the fate of the missing bone,
the researchers examined evidence from both
the fossil record and from the development
of modern bird embryos.
In developing embryos, they used a tracking
technique using stains to see how the bones
formed.
Looking at the more modern birds, the researchers
noticed the ulnare was suspiciously present
in the early stages of development but wasn’t
present in fully grown birds like previously
thought.
But there was a bone there in adult forms.
Upon closer inspection, it was really the
old missing pisiform back again.
The researchers think the reemerging bone
is the result of vestigial genes.
Vestigial limbs or organs, like our tailbone
or appendix are traces of the past.
They are the remains of parts that are no
longer evolutionary advantageous so they either
disappear into our history or become almost
useless.
Over the millennia the genes that coded for
the pisiform were still there, just dormant.
And when they were expressed again, they were
no longer good for walking around on all fours,
but for flying.
So the bone appeared, disappeared and reemerged
to perform a different function, which is
a radical concept for scientists.
The idea of evolutionary reversal is still
met with resistance.
It goes against Dollo’s law, which treats
evolution like a one way street.
Even though several cases of reversal happening
have been identified.
Like teeth reemerging in some South American
frogs after 200 million years of absence.
This recent research is just one piece of
a puzzle that could turn one of the most closely
held scientific concepts on its head.
It’s cool, it’s weird, it’s evolution.
On that note, if you want your web presence
to “evolve” then consider buying a domain
name from domain.com!
No domain extension will help you tell your
story like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
And because you watch DNews, you can get 15%
off Domain Dot Com’s names and web hosting
by using the code DNews when you check out.
What do you think?
Can evolution reverse itself?
What if one day our descendents get their
tails back?
Leave a comment below.
To learn more about the dinosaur to bird evolution,
let trace tell you in this video.
and for more DNews hit that subscribe button,
we post new videos everyday